yeah like in in like the hentai world do
you normally find you find like
that there is like ever certain trends
or like a meta that gets popular between
like different artists
oh
i i'm i'm so curious what the world is
like basically oh yeah i mean like
sometimes there's um
i think i can't think of a good example
like uh oh like recently not too
recently a couple of years ago there was
a meta that was going around that was
like a fixed camera and so like for a
few panels it's like for a few pages
it's the same app oh
oh i remember there's like a time lapse
oh
it's like 11 am they're in missionary
and then it's like 2 am they're in doggy
and it was the same angle
they took a water break
oh my god that is
it reminds me of like that fight scene
in old boy where it's just like one
static camera but you just you just
extrapolate that with sex and that's
just that was just that mess oh my god
that's so weird like i never knew that
there was like you notice it now yeah i
know now that you said it i noticed it i
remember it's like there's like montages
in like 80s films where it's like it's
like
time-lapsing
except it's sex
oh my god yeah now that you say that
i've read so many dozens that use that
yeah recently oh my god i never thought
about that that's crazy
yeah because like i don't know like do
you know how how often do you try to
like break out of the trend or like do
something original or do you
sometimes read some works and you're
like damn that's that's awesome i gotta
incorporate in my own work as well
well
well i don't know if i'm if i'm weird or
not but like it has to interest me yes
i'm not going to have fun drawing it if
i'm not going to have fun drawing it
yeah yeah and i don't do it yeah yeah of
course of course yeah you got to put
your passion in you know some people you
know are really professional and they
just like i i draw what i'm asked you
know but like you draw what's hot you
know yeah right yeah yeah but i can't
really bring myself to do any of that so
like if it doesn't really like you know
[ __ ] interest to me you spoke joy yeah
yeah then i can't do it
like if i'm not drawing it i'd have a
big smile on my face
then it ain't it
so like i respect that you know if
if i wanted to do like a straight-up
like boy meets girl yeah kind of story
then i have to put my own twist on it
yeah otherwise it's not interesting to
me yeah
what would what would the shin no well
twist be in an instance like that i
remember
doing one like basically straightforward
story mm-hmm
which is just like one guy and one girl
just
having sex yeah
and like
i think i made to go like a quad like a
quadruple amputee
i mean like why not right
all right fair enough
vanilla we're gonna get out of here
so like to explain like late she had no
arms nowhere no arms okay
that's like that's like
i feel like that's like as something did
you read a lot of vasanagi during that
time i mean
it was a really wholesome story though
[Laughter]
like
just looking at conor and connor's life
shouldn't discriminate against four
amputees
well that's the end of that scene
i shouldn't and i won't
they deserve sex too yeah exactly
absolutely
just imagining how you draw the panel
was it like we only have x amount of
budget left get rid of the limbs
we don't have enough time to draw the
limbs
it's coming out tomorrow
i think i'm afraid to ask but how'd you
go about researching how to draw the sex
scenes for that well i i knew i got
so i i talked to that person for a bit
and like
asked them like how do you you know is
it awkward having to ask them those
questions okay how i didn't ask like how
do you have sex
they're like how do you like you know go
about doing your daily yeah yeah what do
you find hard to do what do you find
like how do you cope with like you know
not not being able to do this or that um
yeah so that that's really interesting
here so you actually have to like
interview your friend right just to give
yourself a frame of reference
to
to draw that right
if you didn't know someone and you
wanted to kind of ask them how would you
do you have any way of doing that like
if you wanted to meet someone who is in
a certain condition know i don't know
you'd have to like go on the medical
school yeah sure
any paraplegics here
you want to tell me how you [ __ ]
how often do you have to do this kind of
research where you have to like talk to
someone to see what they're experiencing
i mean it's really just it's just for me
basically because yeah yeah i mean i
don't i i figure you could do it without
doing the research or without asking i'm
sure obviously
definitely do not do that yeah yeah for
the drawing but like you know if
for me it like adds a little bit of like
i could add one thing yeah that speaks
true to someone who's experienced it
maybe yeah he's like oh yeah i know how
that feels yeah and if you had that one
thing then like it makes the story a lot
more interesting yeah because i remember
when we did the interview and i and i
asked you about metamorphosis and like
how i think you said and correct me if
i'm wrong but like you the big reason
why you kind of came up with like
sucky's characters because like you've
heard of like you people
who had like similar experiences right
and like
in high school who like you know got
into drugs right but like
it's not based it's not like based on
who are you right right but i'm sure
it's like a lot of it was like kind of
inspired or like you know kind of taken
from that experience right like you know
like
you know someone who's been through a
lot of [ __ ] and like
and sucky's into like all the [ __ ] right
yeah it's like oh she has she had like a
comedically bad life right yeah
but like if you take one aspect of it it
could speak true to someone um
like you know yes that part is i
recognize that part as being real right
right so that makes the story more
engaging have you ever had like anyone
come up to you at like events or
whatever and being like you know i
really like related to like sucky's
character i relate it's like this
particular character that spoke through
today i i get that a lot from like
um yeah sucky oh yeah
damn
i feel bad now yeah
right
i am curious because you said that you
had to
sense yourself for metamorphosis uh
because you were you're drawing it in a
magazine i'm curious now will you ever
release like a director's cut i guess
the schneider card
like 500 pages
because
i i guess even if you couldn't you know
even if you couldn't release it in a
magazine your audience worldwide now is
what vast enough to be able to you know
sell that to because i'd willingly pay
money to see your [ __ ] director of
whatever you had planned originally now
i know i know a lot of people have been
saying like oh shinawa should make like
the happy end right for like
metamorphosis
[Applause]
yeah i think yeah i think it's me when i
was reading i was like i think the one
thing that i was like oh my god is it
it's so fast
right
in one sitting like yeah yeah yeah boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom your
life's ruined your life's routine
your life is over yeah all right there's
no down time yeah yeah yeah there's
literally no break at all and it's just
like you're depressed more depressed
and you're never recovering and it's
like oh okay
all right i guess i'm sad now maybe
that's something you can do on your
patreon right maybe i mean like the
thing about working like in a magazine
or just even doing a dojin is that you
have a certain amount of pages and you
have to have some action in there right
right right so like you know you can't
like spend like like 100 pages like you
know showing someone's life
right god forbid
oh my god i'm actually not [ __ ] in
that time
i'll get bored